ينضم الينا في الاستوديو الدكتور مزمل ابو
القاسم الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
السوداني اهلا بك معنا
بدايه هل هناك امل يتجدد الان مع بقاء
طرفي التفاوض في جده في السعوديه وهذا
الحديث القادم من المملكه العربيه
السعوديه واشنطن بشان محاوله احياء اتفاق
وقف اطلاق النار من جديد للمره الاولى لا
يتم اعلان تمديد الهدنه قبل نهايه يعني
نتحدث عن ست هدى سابق امتدت كل واحده منها
ثلاثه ايام ثم وضدنا امتدت اسبوعا ثم عدنا
امتدت خمسه ايام وانتهت اليوم نتحدث
اصطلاحا عن هدنه ولكن على ارض الواقع لا
توجد هدى لا يوجد اي تقيد بما يتم الاتفاق
عليه في جده لا يوجد التزام ببنود البنود
التي يتفق عليها الطرفان اليوم تحدث شهود
عيان في الع السودانيه الخرطوم عن ان
افراد من الشرطه العسكريه لقوات الدعم
السريع شرعوا في اخراج
افراد من الدعم السريع من بيوت المدنيين
هنا تبدو اشكاليه لان الطرفين
الاتفاق او المسهلان لا يمتلكان اي اليه
تمكنه من التحقق من الخروقات التي تحدث
لجهودنا نتحدث بالتحديد عن نشره قوات
الدعم السريع لقواتها في الاحياء السكنيه
والشكاوى المتصاعده لسكان العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم من احتلال قوات الدعم
السريع لمنازلهم لمراكز الخدمات لكن
بالاساس اتفاقك في اطلاق النار كان الهدف
منه المعلن هو عدم الاضرار بالمدنيين اولا
السماح للمساعدات بالدخول عدم استهداف
المستشفيات والابنيه الحكوميه ونحوها اذا
لم يكن وقف اطلاق النار شاملا للعمليات
العسكريه وهو ما بنى عليه
الاستمرار في العمليات العسكريه اليس كذلك
كلما تفضلت به لم يتم الالتزام به
المواطنون ما زالوا يشتكون في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم ان منازله محتله ما
زالوا يشكون من غياب الخدمات تبعا الى
الاحتلال القوات الدعم السريع لمراكز
الخدمات والسيطره على مراكز الكهرباء صيام
التحكم القومي ايضا
الجيش السوداني يتحدث عن ان الدعم السريع
لم يلتزم بما الزمته به الهدنه عن اخلاع
المستشفيات نتحدث عن اكثر من 60 مستشفى في
العاصمه السوداني الخرطوم محتل حتى هذه
اللحظه وحوالي 12 مستشفى في النواحي
الشماليه من ولايه الجزيره ما زالت حتى
هذه اللحظه بيد قوات الدعم السريع ما زالت
خارج قطاع الخدمه ما زال المواطنون
محرومون من خدمات العلاج وايضا لم تصل اي
مساعدات انسانيه لسكان العصر الخرطوم حتى
هذه اللحظه
يقودنا بالضروره الى الحديث عن ضعف انسياب
المساعدات الانسانيه في الاصل السودان
السودان لم يتلقى من المجتمع الدولي الى
النظره اليسير من المساعدات الانسانيه
لابد من المرور الامن لهذه المساعدات
للوصول وهو ما بنيت عليه هذه العمليه
برمتها جانب السعودي والجانب الامريكي
يراقبان الامر ولم يعني يفارقهم الامل كما
يقولان بان يصل الامر الى وقف جديد لاطلاق
النار انت ترى ان هذا الامر ممكن الان
هم غير موجودين على الارض هناك تفاصيل
تتعلق بهذه الهدى تحتاج الى متابعه
ومراقبه من داخل العاصمه السودانيه موجوده
لدى الطرفين الالتزام لهذه النواحي
النواحي الانسانيه
لا لا يوجد ما يمنع من ايصال المساعدات
الانسانيه للمواطنين اذا التزموا كل طرف
بما تفرضه عليه الهدنه هناك عدم التز وقت
الدعم السريع على اعتبار انها المعنيه بما
بالحديث عن احتلال المستشفيات عن الدخول
منازل المدنيين وسد بها وهي باعترافها
وبحديث ممثليها هي التي تسيطر على مراكز
الخدمات مراكز المياه بيض قوات الدعم
السريع
الكهرباء
والتحكم في العاصمه القوميه القرطوم
تحديدا ايضا الدعم السريع وقد بست وتدعم
السريع فيديوهات من داخل مركز التحكم
القومي وبالتالي اتهامات متبادله بين
الجانبين في هذا الاطار عموما لكن نترك
النقاش عند هذه النقطه شكرا جزيلا لك
الدكتور مزمل ابو القاسم الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي السوداني شكرا جزيلا لك